- If you lie down at night,
and you are not utterly exhausted.
Then you, my friend, do
not want it bad enough.
You have every single thing you need
to do whatever you need to do
and the only person stopping you is you.
Even if two people are
doing the exact same thing,
they're not going to do them
in exactly the same way.
It's unpossible.
You need to find people to work with
that work harder than you, okay.
When you're in the room with them,
you feel guilty because
they're working so hard
and you're like "holy crap, I
need to get my ish together."
- She's a Canadian YouTube
personality, vlogger,
comedian, actress and rapper.
Since starting her
YouTube channel in 2010,
her videos have gained
over 1.5 billion views.
In 2016, Forbes listed
her as number eighth
on the highest paid
YouTube stars in the world.
She's Superwoman Lily Singh,
and here's my take on her
top 10 rules for success.
Rule number one is my personal favorite,
and make sure to stick around
all the way to the end,
for some special bonus clips.
Also as Lily's talking,
if she says something
that really resonates with you,
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so other people
can be inspired as well.
Enjoy.
(profound music)
- What up everyone, it's
your girl Superwoman,
real name Lily Singh.
And you may or may not
know me but either way,
right now that is the
absolutely irrelevant
because I am exactly like you.
I have so many dreams in life,
and so many things that I want to do,
that it both excites
me and stresses me out.
I've had my heart broken so many times
and I am totally terrified of growing up.
I have so many things
to do on my to-do list
and I tell myself I'm going to do them,
but then I spend more
time making my to-do list
than doing things.
And I'm totally content in life,
until I jump onto Facebook
and see another status
about someone getting engaged, oh,
now I'm eating a Mars
bars and googling pictures
of Beyonce and Jay-Z.
And let's just say, although
I'm not their daughter,
I'm still feeling blue.
I get it!
Humans, we're all the same
yet we're so different.
Now speaking of dreams and
passions, one of my passions
is to spread positivity
and that's what I hope to
do in these few minutes,
to you my friend.
So, it has come to my attention,
that a lot of people in the
world want to become something.
They want to achieve something.
They want to reach some sort of goal.
Everyone, whether it's "I want
to be an actor or actress.",
"I want to open my own business."
"I want a six pack."
"I want a Bugatti."
Everyone wants something,
anything, everything.
You, for example, just take a second,
think about what you want in life.
What do you want to become?
What do you really, really desire?
Think about it.
You got it in your brain?
Okay, so you're thinking about it.
Good, good, good.
Now keep in mind that
there's so many other people
in the world, right now, that
claim they want something
really, really bad.
Okay.
Now the purpose of this
video is for me to stand here
and call you out and say,
you don't want these things so badly,
because if you wanted them so badly,
you'd be getting them.
Now before you cuss me
out and close this video,
let me br-- br-- br--
break it down for you.
If you lie down at night and
you are not utterly exhausted,
then you, my friend, do
not want it bad enough.
Because if you have a dream or a goal
and the concept of sleep
does not seem foreign to you,
then you sleep too much.
Because when you trying to reach a goal,
sleep should feel like a guilty pleasure.
You should go to sleep at night,
when your head hits that
pillow, it's a straight seven!
The straight up,
praise the lord, I'm a get some zzz's.
And here's the thing, right?
I hear people complaining all the time
about being broke, not
achieving their goals,
nothing ever goes their way.
But then those are the same
people that go to sleep,
'cause they're too tired.
Stop working 'cause they're too lazy.
Can't drive to a meeting
'cause it's too far.
Can't network with people
because they don't like them.
Who can't finish a project
because the game is on.
Who can't take on a challenge
because it's too much work.
So to you, I say, "Hi, hello.
Welcome to the real world."
Where as hard as you think you're working,
there's many people working
10 times harder than you.
So let me just ask you a question,
why do you feel that you deserve success?
Why do you deserve to reach new heights,
and achieve great things?
Because this is the
reality of the situation,
you can be doing anything,
say you're a musician,
and you wake up and you
spend hours and hours
and hours practicing and working on music.
And then at night when you're
tired, you go to sleep,
and you're like "you know
what, I worked really hard."
I can tell you, that somewhere out there,
there's another musician whose choosing
to stay up that one extra hour
and that's putting in more
grind than you, my friend.
A.k.a. what I'm trying to tell you
is all these people who have dreams
and say they want to become something,
and say "the world is against them."
Sweetie, the world
isn't against you, okay?
Your excuses are against you.
So hi, hello, my name is Lily,
I go by the name of Superwoman,
if you don't know me, now you do,
and we're friends, what's up?
Whoever you are, whether
you know me or not,
watch my videos or not,
even if you've seen me for the first time,
you have a dream, you
want to achieve something,
stop watching this video.
Okay, watch the video.
Ain't no harm in watching the video.
Watch the video.
But after this video,
okay, achieve something.
How do you know not to touch
the stove when it's on?
Chances are when you were younger,
you burnt yourself a few times
and now you know it you
touch it, it's going to hurt.
But how you would know that
if you didn't burn yourself
in the first place?
As humans, we learn through mistakes.
How do you know how to walk?
Because when you were a toddler,
you fell on your butt
a couple hundred times.
Now that concept doesn't change over time.
From the moment which you were born,
to the moment which you die.
You will always learn things
because you f--ed things up.
Or because someone hurt you.
Look back, honestly take
a second and look back
at every lesson you've ever learned
and I can guarantee you
that lesson is founded
on strong mistakes, heartache, tears,
and a whole lot of other sad things.
If you've learned who to trust,
it's probably because
someone has lied to you.
And if you've learned how to be positive,
it's probably because
you've been negative.
And if you have the app, Find
my Iphone, on your Iphone,
it's probably because you lost you Iphone.
So when you make a mistake or
you fail or you're heartbroken
yeah, cry, be sad about it.
That's okay.
But also be 10% happy
because yo, this is going to
teach you something amazing
that will help you in the future.
There is a huge silver
lining to everything.
Picture it as exercise for your soul.
The biggest people make in life,
is thinking that their
brain controls them,
when really they control their brain.
Let me show you right now,
Touch your nose.
No, no, stop what you're doing right now,
just touch your nose.
Did you touch it?
You touched it, right?
Congratulations (clapping)
But O-M-G, how did you do that?
You did that because you told your brain
you wanted to touch your nose.
So question for you,
why is it that when you're
scared, upset or angry,
suddenly you can't do things?
Because my question is,
how can you not do things when you're
in total control of yourself?
Because, can I be real with you?
You can do whatever you want to do
as soon as you stop making excusing,
and start taking ownership.
Touch your nose, complete a task.
Same the same.
But hold up, let's be
real, this is YouTube
and we all know at least
one person's going to
comment below and be like,
"Okay but what if my hands
are tied behind my back,
and there's a hurricane
inside of a world war
and my dog ate my homework?
I'm not in control then."
And this is where I'm going
to reference my good friend,
Mr. Bob Marley who says,
"None but ourselves can free our mind."
Because although there are
CEOs, there are parents,
and there are presidents,
no one in this world has more
power over you and your mind,
than you.
Now don't get me wrong, homey, okay,
You may have difficult
circumstances indeed,
but that's perfect,
that's why we have such
an amazing mind and soul.
But you got to remember,
even though your mind
and soul are amazing,
that doesn't mean that
they don't get hurt.
And when they get hurt,
you got to remember that
negatives aren't forever.
Because let's be real, baby,
how many times have you take a negative
and developed it into a beautiful picture?
And if you can't remember,
let me remind you.
Remember when you were younger,
and you lost your best friend.
Or when your dog died.
Or when your fish died.
Or last week, when your
favorite Game of Thrones
character died and you were like
"life is terrible, I'm
never getting over this."
Hi, hello, you're still here.
You're still existing, I see you.
That's because everything you
thought you couldn't overcome,
you've overcome.
So logically, it's a bit
ridiculous for you to assume
that you can't do things,
when you've, in fact, been doing them.
You have every single thing you need
to do whatever you need to do
and the only person stopping you is you.
In life, people will hate on what you do,
and this is my take on it,
it's not natural to be like
"Oh, I'm going to go on this girl's video
and write she's a whore. Dah, dah, dah."
That's not a natural thing to do.
The only reason someone would do that
is because they're dealing
with their own insecurities.
Someone doesn't like something,
they can easily ignore it.
But when people feel the
need to go out of their way
and comment on Twitter,
YouTube and Facebook,
that just means that they're
just really frickin' insecure.
And if you do have haters,
which inevitably everybody will have,
handle it like a bawse!
At the end of the day,
all of the people that want
to tweet their witty comments
on Twitter or on Facebook or on YouTube,
I'll never respond, why?
Because you're still
watching what I'm doing.
You're commenting underneath
my video, giving me a view,
who's really winning?
Even under this video, someone
will write a hate comment.
Many people will, why?
Because they're mad at
what I'm saying right now,
and they're mad that I'm calling them out,
they feel bad about themselves.
And they wish they could wear a winter hat
in the middle of summer.
And they wish they had
this freakin, where is it?
Pimple right here.
They wish they did, you wish you did.
(coughs)
You have a hater that's
super annoying and is like,
and you have a hater that's super annoying
and like keeps bothering you,
just agree with them and
tell them to shut the f- up.
Dude, how did you know I'm a whore?
How did you know?
How could I not have
noticed that I'm black?
I feel so stupid.
I can't believe you knew
I was black and I didn't.
Oh my god, you're right, I
do curry and I am smelly.
I'm going to go take a shower and Febreze.
Everyone says they're "working"
but I believe one percent of
people are actually working.
The other 99% of people are
just making to-do lists.
And to-do lists are great.
Unless you're doing them
wrong, in which case,
they're totally pointless.
Because some people out
here treating to-do lists
like they're vision boards.
Like they're f-in bucket
lists, like f-in life goals.
Tell me if you can relate,
have you ever made a to-do
list that looks like this?
Finish essay.
Read chapters 1-5.
Buy new jacket.
Respond to all emails in inbox.
Clean room.
Find true love.
Grow hair so I can do that cute braid.
Learn to play chess.
Get six pack.
And if that's what your
to-do list looks like,
you, my friend, need to calm the f-- down,
okay, because post-its aren't genies.
They don't make wishes come true.
Aladdin took place Agrawbah,
not f-in Office Depot.
And I know, I know when
you're making a to-do list,
it's so tempting to think
that you're invincible
and you're going to do all
this stuff today, okay.
You been writing your to-do list
and it looks like the f-in lyrics to
Rihanna and Drake's new song.
It's like ♫ "Work, Work, Work, Work, Work"
Just be real.
I find the key is to have two to-do lists,
one for things you're going to do today,
a.k.a. before you sleep.
And one for longer term goals.
Example, today: read chapter one.
Longer term goal: read
chapters one through five.
If you want, you can even
have a third list called,
LOL, where you write things like,
find true love.
(laughs)
So yo, check this out, right.
I'm about to blow your mind.
No one on this planet
is crazy in the same way
that you are crazy.
No one is you, no one has the
same characteristics as you.
Which means no one can
do exactly what you do.
Even if people are doing
the exact same thing,
they're not going to do them
in exactly the same way.
It's unpossible!
Two dancers can't dance exactly the same.
Two artists can't paint exactly the same.
Two doctors will not heal
people in exactly the same way.
That's just the bloody facts.
Okay, and I know what you're thinking,
"yo, what the f- Lily,
why you being so tumbler,
let me explain though."
If no one can be exactly like you,
that means it doesn't
make any sense for you
to compete with other people.
The only person you have to compete with,
is the older version of yourself.
Stay with me.
You are going to succeed,
are you ready for this?
because the world is waiting
for what you have to offer
because no one else can offer
exactly what you have to offer
and if you don't work hard and
you waste that opportunity,
it's like you didn't show
up to a job interview
that you already had in the bag.
So, don't be damn you, don't be damn you.
My camera.
You know I see people
stressing all the time
about this, about that and 'about
all the problems in their life
and I'm here to just keep it real and say,
your problems are so important
but really they're not important at all.
And let me explain.
Something might be
bothering you right now,
and that's totally cool.
It is important in your life
and no one else understand it,
that's fine, but baby look around.
Life is waiting for you to live it.
So go ahead, smile, be
happy, make a new friend,
take a trip, treat yourself.
Get up, randomly dance, right now.
So be happy, because I promise you,
as important as your problems are,
they are not nearly as important
as all of the good
things you got going on.
I'm sure this is not the
first time you heard this,
but it is significantly
easier to get work done
when you're surrounded
by like-minded people.
In fact, that is almost half
of the reason I moved to L.A.
But this is not about
me, this is about you.
That doesn't mean that you got
to move to another country.
I mean you can if you want
to but you ain't got to do--
but if you in L.A., yo hit me up.
If you're lucky, the people who hustle
and motivate you are your friends.
But can I be honest, they're likely not.
I bet your friends are so great
at holding your hair back while you puke.
At eating pizza with you,
at golfing with you, taking
ugly selfies with you,
hanging out with you,
watching movies with you.
Great, do all that stuff with them.
But if they're not great
at working with you,
why are you with them when
you're trying to get work done?
You need to find people to work with,
that work harder than you.
Okay?
When you're in a room
with them, you feel guilty
because they're working
so hard and you're like,
"holy crap, I need to
get my ish together."
And if that's not your
friends, then so be it.
That means it's okay to say, hey no,
you can't come over
'cause I have work to do.
Different people work in
different sit-iations.
Feel confident.
Dress to impress yourself.
When you leave the house,
look at the mirror.
Look at yourself and if you don't go,
"Ssssh,
daaaamn!"
Then you need to change.
Feel like a million bucks.
And that doesn't mean you
have to spend a million bucks.
You don't need that Gucci
Gucci, Fendi Fendi, Prada Prada,
You can be rockin' that
straight 725 from Wal-Mart,
and still be hella hot.
I'm saying make sure
when you leave the house,
you're dressed in an outfit
that you feel confident in.
If you're worrying
about your crack showing
and you know your booby popping out,
and your pants being too tight
or too loose or something,
you're not going to feel confident.
You need to feel sexy,
you need to feel hot.
You need to feel smokin'.
And everyone is beautiful
in their own way,
so don't give me no BS about,
"I'm ugly and my hair is ugly
and my skin is ugly, and my--"
The hell was that?
"And my skin is ugly
and just everything--"
No, everyone is beautiful
in their own way,
so don't give me that crap, okay?
That means you just need to
connect with your inner sway,
and get it poppin', alright.
(sigh)
So you're sitting there,
standing there, lying there,
watching this video and life
has beaten the crap out of you.
I'm talking straight black eye status.
You're crippled emotionally
and mentally scarred.
People have hurt you, ish has happened,
you lost your boyfriend,
you lost your girlfriend,
you lost your job.
Life has kicked you in the genitals,
over and over and over and over,
and you just cannot take it, you give up.
I get it, I do.
I know what that feels like
and so I'm here to tell you,
to get the hell back up!
If you fall 899 times,
you get back up 900 times.
Trust me, I fall all the time.
I was falling through most of my life.
If I fell on Monday, on
Tuesday, the sun still rose.
And if I fell on Wednesday, on Thursday,
the sun still rose, because, you know why?
It doesn't matter if
you're miserable or not,
the world doesn't care
if you're in a good mood,
or it you're happy.
The sun will always
still rise the next day.
And you, my friend, will be left behind.
So brother, sister, from
the heart, get back up!
And do it for you.
And let me tell you what I mean by that.
If everyone went out and
tried to seek revenge
on everyone who hurt them,
the world would be hot mess.
Moreso than it already is.
I would have killed Fido by now.
I would have been a compulsive liar.
I definitely would have
bombed Rims headquarters.
I'd be a player.
I'd be a crappy friend.
And I would back stab people just for fun.
Straight Friday the 13th status, just--
But no, because two wrongs
do not make a right,
and a lot of people ask me,
"Lily, is the reason you work
so hard and try to succeed
because you want to prove
all those people wrong?
All those people that hurt you
and said you couldn't do it,
you want to make them feel stupid?"
And my answer, honestly, genuinely, is no.
My success should not
be driven by the need
to make other people feel stupid.
What would I accomplish by that?
But you know what my success is driven by?
The need to prove myself wrong.
Because back in the day,
yes people did hurt me.
They hurt me so bad.
Trust me, I know what
that hurt feels like.
But do I want to prove them wrong?
No, I want to prove myself wrong.
Because for a moment I did feel worthless,
I did feel like I wasn't good enough.
So I prove that Lily wrong, that old Lily.
Lily, f-- you, I will prove you wrong.
I don't need to define my goals
by proving other people
wrong and neither do you.
So don't keep in mind all
the people that hurt you,
to seek revenge on them, no.
Just remember how they made
you feel, and prove that wrong.
Because you're better than that.
And if along the way, a few
people feel dumb, so be it!
So this is my video to tell you,
I know stuff happens in life.
People fall, there's ups and downs.
You may feel worthless,
pathetic right now.
You may have given up, but I'm here
to tell you to get back up.
And do it for yourself.
Thank you guys so much for watching.
I made this video because
Melvin Johnson asked me to.
So if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next,
leave it down in the comments below,
and I'll see what I can do.
I'd also love to know,
what did Lily say that had
the biggest impact on you?
What message really meant the most to you,
that you're going to immediately apply
to your business or life,
leave it in the comments and I'm going to
join in the discussion.
Finally I wanted to give a quick shout-out
to Marisha Rodriguez, RishyCup TV,
thank you so much for
picking up a copy of my book,
and sharing it on Facebook.
I really, really, really,
really appreciate it.
So thank you guys again for watching,
I believe in you,
I hope you continue to
believe in yourself.
And whatever your one word is, much love.
I'll see you soon.
You know when you're pissed
off or having a bad day,
and you just feel like the
universe is against you,
and everything's going wrong.
Let me break it down to you, okay.
The universe does not give
an f-- about you, my friend.
Nobody cares to piss you off.
Uh, hello, who do yo think you are?
Mother Nature, Zeus,
Gandalf, frickin' Dumbledore.
They have other ish to do,
they're not spending their
time plotting against you.
Ain't nobody got time for that.
It's simple.
If you want to have a good
day, act like a good person.
What you think you could
just be rude, ignorant,
and be obnoxious to everyone
and they're going to treat you well?
You should write a book.
How to be Dummy for Dummies.
Homey, let me break it down for you.
If you send out back
vibes by lying, cheating,
stealing, anything.
Making fun of people, gossiping,
posting a hate comment
under my YouTube videos.
You, my friend, are putting
your focus, energy and attention
on negativity so throughout your day,
what do you think you're
going to recognize?
You're going to notice that "fat girl".
That idiot guy, that scratch on your car,
that person that cut you off,
and you're going to totally
ignore, that fine guy,
that person that held
the door open for you,
or your own friend that you
haven't seen in 10 years,
walk right by you.
But not to fear, you
might be stressed out,
you might be thinking,
"yeah, really how can
I send out good vibes?"
Lily, tell me which number
I should text a message: good vibe.
Because you so used to being a surrr face.
It's really simple, stop
right now, pick up your phone,
send a nice text message to someone.
Tweet someone a compliment
@iisuperwomanii, just sayin'.
Message an old friend, go hug your family.
You know what, stop the video right now.
Stop the video right now.
Pause the video, pause the video.
I'll wait right here, go 'head.
Are you back?
Are you back, okay.
Well now that's you're
listening to me anyways,
click thumbs up, like the video.
Stay cool, moving on.
I think one of the messages
I'm very big on in my show,
is I don't like to say
things that are cliche',
or cute and adorable, I like to real.
I tell my audience that some
people wish for their dreams,
and other people work for their dreams.
Be the person who works for your dreams.
It's not going to be pretty,
it's not going to be cute,
it's not going to be fun all the time.
It just is going to
take a lot of hard work.
And I encourage you all to do that.
It's not enough to dream a
dream, you got to work for it.
Always, everyday, everyday.
(laughs)
From the very beginning,
I'm myself Asian female
making videos, I mean,
I get racism and sexism,
and everything combined.
Of course, I think no
matter what you put online,
there's going to be controversy.
I've learned very quickly on the internet,
you cannot please everyone.
I have a video called 10 Reasons to Smile
and there's still dislikes on it.
That's an indication that
no matter what you do,
people will dislike it.
And there's been controversy over me being
an Indian female talking
about relationships,
and talking about kissing and
talking about those things and
The best I can do is do
what I think is right
and that's what I'm doing.